Professor Shelly Kagan:
Last time we ended with the
following puzzle or question.
If we say that to be a person
is to be a P-functioning
body, it seems then as though we
have to conclude that when
you're not P-functioning,
you're dead.
That is, you're dead as a
person.
Previously, we distinguished
between the death of my body and
my death as a person;
let's focus on my death as a
person.
If I'm not
P-functioning,
do we have to then say I'm
dead?
Well, that may seem to be the
most natural way to define
death, but it's not an
acceptable approach.
Because it would follow then,
that when I'm asleep,
I'm dead.
Well, not during those times,
perhaps, when I'm dreaming
while I'm asleep.
But think of the various
periods during the night in
which you are in a deep,
deep dreamless sleep.
You're not thinking.
You're not planning.
You're not communicating.
Let's just suppose,
as seems likely,
that none of the
P-functioning is
occurring, at some point during
sleep.
Should we say then that you're
dead?
Well, that's clearly not the
right thing to say.
So we need to revise our
account of what it is on the
physicalist picture to say that
you're dead.
What is it to be dead?
It can't just be a matter of
not P-functioning.
Well, one possibility would be
to say, the question is not
whether you are
P-functioning.
It's okay if you're not
P-functioning,
as long as your not
P-functioning is
temporary.
If you will P-function
again, if you have been
P-functioning in the past
and you will be
P-functioning again in
the future,
P-functioning for person
functioning, you will be
P-functioning again in
the future,
then you're not dead.
Well, that's at least an
improvement, because then we
say, look, while you're asleep,
even though there's no
P-functioning going on,
the lack of
P-functioning is
temporary,
so you're still alive.
But I think that won't quite do
either.
Let's suppose that come
Judgment Day,
God will resurrect the dead.
And let's just suppose the
correct theory of personal
identity is such as to put aside
any worries we might have along
with van Inwagen,
that we discussed previously,
as to whether or not on
resurrection day that would
really be you or not.
Suppose it would be you.
So God will resurrect the dead.
Judgment Day comes.
The dead are resurrected.
Well, now they're
P-functioning.
So it turns out that during
that period in which they were
dead, they were only temporarily
not P-functioning.
But if death means permanent
cessation of
P-functioning,
then it turns out the dead
weren't really dead after all.
They were only temporarily not
P-functioning,
just like we are temporarily
not P-functioning when
we're asleep.
Well, that doesn't seem right
either.
On Judgment Day,
God resurrects the dead.
It's not that He simply wakes
up those in a deep,
deep sleep.
So the proposal that death is a
matter of permanent cessation of
P-functioning versus
temporary,
that doesn't seem like it's
going to do the trick.
But what else do we have up our
sleeves?
Here's a different proposal
that I think is probably closer
to the right account.
We might say,
look, while you're asleep,
it's true that you're not
P-functioning.
For example,
you're not doing your
multiplication tables.
But although you are not
engaged in P-functioning,
it does seem true to say that
you still can P-function.
You still could do your
multiplication tables.
Although it's not true that you
are speaking French--let's
suppose that you know how to
speak French--it's still true of
you while you're asleep that you
can or could speak French.
How do we know this?
Well, all we have to do is just
wake you up.
We wake you up and we say,
"Hey John, what's three times
three?"
And after you stop swearing at
us, you say, "Well,
it's nine."
Or we say, "Linda,
hey, conjugate such and such a
verb in French."
And you can conjugate it.
Even though you were not
engaged in P-functioning
while you were asleep,
it's still true that while you
were asleep, you had the ability
to engage in
P-functioning.
Abilities aren't always
actualized.
Your P-functioning is
actualized now,
because you're engaged in
thought,
but you don't lose the ability
to think during those moments
when you're not thinking.
Suppose we say then that to be
alive as a person is to be able
to engage in
P-functioning.
And to be dead then,
is to be unable to engage in
P-functioning.
Why are you unable?
Well, presumably because
whatever cognitive structures it
takes in your brain to
underwrite the ability to
P-function,
those cognitive structures have
been broken, so they no longer
work.
It's--When you're dead,
your brain is broken.
It's not just that you're not
engaged in P-functioning,
you're no longer able to
engage in P-functioning.
That, at least,
seems to handle the case of
sleep properly.
Although you're not engaged in
P-functioning,
you're able to,
so you're still alive.
Take the dead who will be
resurrected on Judgment Day.
Although they will be engaged
in P-functioning later
on, it's not true right now that
they can engage in
P-functioning.
Their bodies and brains are
broken until God fixes them.
So they're dead.
All right, that seems to give
the right answer and,
in fact, it gives us some
guidance how to think about some
other puzzling cases.
Take somebody who is in a coma,
not engaged in
P-functioning.
Their body, let's stipulate,
is still alive.
Their heart's still beating,
the lungs are still breathing
and so forth.
But we wonder,
is the person still alive?
Does the person still exist?
Well, they're not engaged in
P-functioning.
That's pretty clear.
We want to know,
can they engage in
P-functioning?
Now, at this point we'd want to
know more about the underlying
mechanics about what's gone on
in the case of the coma.
If the following is the right
description, then we perhaps
should say they're still alive.
Look, when somebody's asleep,
we need to do something to,
in effect, wake them up,
something to turn the
functioning back on.
The cognitive structures are
still there, but the on-off
switch is switched to off.
Perhaps that's what it's like
when somebody's in a coma,
or perhaps at least certain
types of comas.
Of course, to turn the on-off
switch on is harder when
somebody's in a coma.
It's a bit more--to continue
with the metaphor of the on-of
switch--as though not only is
the switch turned to off,
there's a lock on the switch.
And so we can't turn the switch
on in the normal way.
Pushing the person in the coma
and saying, "Wake up,
Jimmy" doesn't do the trick.
But for all that,
although the on-off switch may
be stuck in off,
if the underlying cognitive
structures of the brain are such
as to still make it true that,
flip the on switch back to on
and the person can still engage
in cognitive
P-functioning,
maybe the right thing to say is
the person's still alive.
Coma case two.
I'm not sure whether this
really should be called a coma.
I don't know the biological and
medical details.
But imagine that what's gone on
is there's been decay of the
brain structures that underwrite
the cognitive functioning.
So now it's not just that the
on-off switch is stuck in off,
the brain's no longer capable
of engaging in these higher
order P-functions.
This might be a persistent
vegetative state with no
possibility of turning it on,
even in principle.
Of such a person we might say,
they're no longer capable of
P-functioning.
And then perhaps the right
thing to say is the person no
longer exists,
so they no longer exist as a
person, even if the body is
still alive.
So far, so good.
Here's a harder case to think
about.
Suppose we put somebody in a
state of suspended animation,
cool their body down so that
the various metabolic processes
come to an end.
They stop.
As I'm sure you know,
we're able, with various lower
organisms, to put them in a
state of suspended animation and
then,
the amazing thing is,
if you heat them back up again
properly, they start functioning
again.
Now, we can't do that yet with
humans.
But it doesn't jump out at us,
at least, that that should be
an impossibility.
So suppose we eventually learn
how to do this with humans.
And now, suppose we take Larry
and put him in a state of
suspended animation.
Is he dead?
Well, most of us don't feel
comfortable saying that he's
dead.
Just like we don't feel
comfortable saying that the--I
suppose we could do this with a
fruit fly.
I don't know whether we can or
can't.
Suppose we can.
Suppose we do it with a fruit
fly.
We don't feel comfortable
saying the fruit fly's dead.
Rather, it's in a state of
suspended animation.
Well, similarly then,
perhaps we wouldn't want to say
that Larry is dead.
And the "brokenness" account of
death allows us to say Larry's
not dead.
The structures in the brain
which would underwrite the
ability to engage in
P-functioning,
they're not destroyed by
suspended animation.
So perhaps in the relevant
sense, the person can still
engage in P-functioning,
so they're not dead.
Good enough.
On the other hand,
it doesn't seem so plausible,
it doesn't seem intuitively
right, to say that they're
alive.
Is Larry alive when he's in a
state of suspended animation?
No.
It seems like he's not alive
either.
Now that's a bit puzzling,
right?
It's as though we
need--Normally,
we think that look,
either you're alive or you're
dead.
The two possibilities exhaust
the possibilities.
But thinking about suspended
animation suggests that we may
actually need a third category,
suspended--neither alive nor
dead.
Well, all right,
if we do introduce a third
possibility--I'm not sure this
is the right thing.
It's not clear what's the right
or best thing to say about
suspended animation.
But at least that doesn't seem
like an unattractive
possibility.
If there are three
possibilities--dead,
alive, or suspended--to be
dead, we could still say you've
got to be broken,
incapable of
P-functioning.
Suspended isn't broken.
It's just suspended.
But then what do you need to be
alive?
In addition to not being
broken, what do you need to be
alive?
Well, the initially tempting
thing to say is not only aren't
you broken, but you're actually
engaged in P-functioning.
But if we say that,
then we're back to saying that
somebody who's asleep isn't
really alive.
That doesn't seem right either.
So we need some account to
distinguish between suspended
animation and out and out being
alive.
And I'm not quite sure how to
draw that line.
So I'll leave that to you as a
puzzle to work on on your own.
That puzzle aside,
it seems to me that once we
become physicalists,
there's nothing especially deep
or mysterious about death.
The body is able to function in
a variety of ways.
When some of those lower
biological functions are
occurring, the body's alive.
When all goes well,
the body is also capable of
engaging in higher order
personal P-functioning.
And then you've got a person.
The body begins to break,
you get the loss of
P-functioning.
At that point,
you no longer exist as a
person.
When the body breaks some more,
you get the loss of biological
or B-functioning,
and then the body dies.
There's nothing especially
mysterious about death,
although there may be a lot of
details to work out from a
scientific point of view.
What are the particular
processes that underwrite
biological functioning?
What are the particular
processes that underwrite
personality or person
functioning?
Still, there are a couple of
claims about death that get made
frequently enough,
about death being mysterious in
one way or another,
that I want--or special or
unique--that I want to focus on.
In effect, from the physicalist
point of view,
although death is unique
because it comes at the end of
this lifetime of various sorts
of functions,
there's nothing especially
puzzling, nothing especially
mysterious, nothing especially
unusual or hard to grasp about
it.
But there are a handful of
claims that people make about
death suggesting that they
think,
and they think we all think,
that death is mysterious or
unique or hard to comprehend.
I want to examine a couple of
these.
One of them I'll get to later;
if not later today,
then next lecture.
Sometimes people say that we
die alone or everybody
dies alone.
And this is something--This is
supposed to express some deep
insight into the nature and
uniqueness of death.
So although we're able to eat
meals together,
we're able to go on vacations
together and take classes
together,
death is something we all have
to do by ourselves.
That's the claim.
We all die alone.
That's a claim I'll come back
to.
What I want to look at first is
the suggestion that somehow,
at some level,
nobody really believes they're
going to die at all.
Now, having distinguished
between what we've called the
death of the body and the death
of the person,
the question whether or not
you're going to die needs to be
distinguished.
The question whether or not you
believe you're going to die
needs to be distinguished.
If somebody says,
"You know, nobody really
believes they're going to die,"
they could mean one of two
things.
They could mean nobody really
believes they're going to cease
to exist as a person,
first possibility.
Second possible claim,
nobody really believes they're
going to undergo the death of
their bodies.
Let's take these in turn.
Is there any good reason to
believe that we don't believe
that we're going to cease to
exist as a person?
Well, the most common argument
for this claim I think takes the
following form.
People sometimes say,
since it's impossible to
picture being dead,
it's impossible to picture
being dead--,
That is to say,
it's impossible to picture your
own being dead.
Each one of us has to think
about this from the first person
perspective or something like
that.
Think about your dying,
your being dead--Since that's
impossible to picture,
that's impossible to imagine,
nobody believes in the
possibility that they're going
to die,
that they're going to cease to
exist.
The idea seems to be that you
can't believe in possibilities
that you can't picture or
imagine.
Now, that hypothesis,
that thesis,
that assumption,
could be challenged.
I think probably we shouldn't
believe the theory of belief
which says that in order to
believe in something,
you've got to be able to
picture it or believe it.
But let's grant that assumption
for the sake of argument.
Let's suppose that in order to
believe in something,
you've got to be able to
picture it.
What then?
How do we get from there to the
conclusion that I can't believe
that I'm going to die,
I'm going to cease to exist as
a person?
Well, the thought,
of course, is I can't picture
or imagine my death.
I can't picture or imagine my
being dead.
It's important here to draw
some distinctions.
I can certainly picture being
ill.
There I am on my deathbed dying
of cancer, growing weaker and
weaker.
I can perhaps even picture the
moment of my death.
I've said goodbye to my family
and friends.
I've the--Everything's growing
greyer and dimmer.
It's growing harder and harder
to concentrate.
And then, well,
and then there is no "and
more."
The claim, however,
is not that I can't picture
being ill or dying.
The claim's got to be,
I can't picture being
dead.
Well, try it.
Try to picture being dead.
What's it like to be dead?
Sometimes people claim it's a
mystery.
We don't know what it's like to
be dead, because every time we
try to imagine it,
we fail.
We don't do a very good job.
I'm inclined to think that that
way of thinking about the
question is really confused.
You set yourself the goal of
trying to put yourself in the
situation imaginatively of what
it's like to be dead.
So I start by trying to strip
off the parts of my conscious
life that I know I won't have
when I'm dead.
I won't hear anything.
I won't see anything.
I won't think anything.
And you try to imagine what
it's like to not think or feel
or hear or see.
And you don't do a very good
job of it.
So you throw your hands up and
you say, "Oh,
I guess I don't know what it's
like."
So it must be a mystery.
It's not a mystery at all.
Suppose I ask,
"What's it like to be this cell
phone?"
The answer is,
"It's not like anything," where
that doesn't mean there's
something that it's like to be a
cell phone,
but different from being
anything else.
So it's not like anything else;
it's a special way of
feeling or experiencing.
No.
Cell phones don't have any
experience at all.
There is nothing that
it's like on the inside to be a
cell phone.
Imagine that I try to ask
myself, "What's it like to be my
ball point pen?"
And I try to imagine,
well, first,
imagine being really,
really stiff,
because you're not flexible
when you're a ball point pen.
You can't move.
And imagine being really,
really bored,
because you don't have any
thoughts or interests.
No.
That's completely the wrong way
to go about thinking what it's
like to be a ball point pen.
There's nothing that
it's like to be a ball point
pen.
There's nothing to describe,
nothing to imagine.
No mystery about what it's like
to be a ball point pen.
to be a cell phone.
Well, similarly then,
I put it to you,
there's no mystery about what
it's like to be dead.
It isn't like anything.
What I don't mean,
"Oh, it's like something,
but different from everything
else."
I mean, there is nothing there
to describe.
When you're dead,
there's nothing happening on
the inside to be imagined.
Well, should we conclude
therefore, given that we've got
the premise, "If you can't
picture it or imagine it,
then you can't believe in it,"
since I've just said,
look, you can't imagine being
dead,
but that's not due to any
failure of imagination,
that's because there's nothing
there to imagine or picture.
Still, granted the premise,
if you can't picture it or
imagine it, you can't believe in
it--Should we conclude,
therefore, that you can't
believe you're going to be dead?
No.
We shouldn't conclude that.
After all, not only is it true
that you can't picture from the
inside what it's like to be
dead,
you can't picture from the
inside what it's like to be in
dreamless sleep.
There is nothing that it's like
to be in dreamless sleep.
When you're in dreamless sleep,
you're not imagining or
experiencing anything.
Similarly, it's not possible to
picture or imagine what it's
like to have fainted and be
completely unconscious with
nothing happening cognitively.
There's nothing to picture or
imagine.
Well, should we conclude,
therefore, so nobody really
believes that they're ever in
dreamless sleep?
Well, that would be silly.
Of course you believe that at
times you're in dreamless sleep.
Should we say of somebody who's
fainted or knows that they're
subject to fainting spells,
they never actually believe
that they pass out?
That would be silly.
Of course, they believe they
pass out.
From the mere fact that they
can't picture it from the
inside, it doesn't follow that
nobody believes they're ever in
dreamless sleep.
From the mere fact that they
can't picture from the inside
what it's like to have fainted
and not yet woken up,
it doesn't mean that nobody
believes that they ever faint.
From the mere fact that you
can't picture from the inside
what it's like to be dead,
it doesn't follow that nobody
believes they're going to die.
But didn't I start off by
saying I was going to grant the
person who is making this
argument that in order to
believe something,
you've got to be able to
picture it?
And haven't I just said,
"Look, you can't picture being
dead"?
So aren't I taking it back?
Since I say you can believe
you're going to die,
yet you can't picture it from
the inside.
Haven't I taken back the
assumption that in order to
believe it, you've got to be
able to picture it?
Not quite.
Although I am skeptical about
that claim, I am going to
continue giving it to the person
who makes this argument,
because I'm not so prepared to
admit that you can't picture
being dead.
You can picture being dead,
all right.
You just can't picture it from
the inside.
You can picture it from the
outside.
I can picture being in
dreamless sleep quite easily.
I'm doing it right now.
I've got a little mental image
of my body lying in bed asleep,
dreamlessly.
I can picture fainting,
or having fainted,
quite easily.
Picture my body lying on the
ground unconscious.
I can picture my being dead
quite easily.
It's a little mental picture of
my body in a coffin.
No functioning occurring in my
body.
So even if it were true that
belief requires picturing,
and even if were true that you
can't picture being dead from
the inside,
it wouldn't follow that you
can't believe you're going to
die.
All you have to do is picture
it from the outside.
We're done.
So I conclude,
of course you can and do
believe you're going to die.
But at this point,
the person making the argument
has a possible response.
And it's a quite common
response.
He says, "Look,
I try to picture the
world--admittedly from the
outside--I try to picture the
world in which I don't exist,
I'm no longer conscious.
I'm no longer a person,
no longer experiencing
anything.
I try to picture that world.
I picture, for example,
seeing my funeral.
And yet, when I try to do that,
I'm observing it.
I'm watching the funeral.
I'm seeing the funeral.
Consequently, I'm thinking.
So I haven't really imagined
the world in which I no longer
exist, a world in which I'm
dead,
a world in which I'm incapable
of thought and observation.
I've smuggled myself back in as
the observer of the funeral."
Every time I try to picture
myself being dead,
I smuggle myself back in,
conscious and existing as a
person, hence,
not dead as a person.
Maybe my body--I'm imagining my
body dead, but I'm not imagining
myself, the person,
dead.
From which it follows,
the argument goes,
that I don't really believe
I'll ever be dead.
Because when I try to imagine a
world in which I'm dead,
I smuggle myself back in.
This argument shows up in
various places.
Let me mention,
let me quote one case of it,
Freud.
Freud says, this is,
I'm quoting from one of the
Walter Kaufman essays that
you'll be reading,
called "Death."
He quotes Freud.
Freud says,
After all,
one's own death is beyond
imagining, and whenever we try
to imagine it we can see that we
really survive as spectators.
Thus, the dictum could be dared
in the psychoanalytic school:
at bottom, nobody believes in
his own death.
Or, and this is the same:
in his unconscious,
every one of us is convinced of
his immortality.
All right, there's Freud.
Basically, just running the
argument I've just sketched for
you.
When you try to imagine your
being dead, you smuggle yourself
back in as a spectator.
And so, Freud concludes,
at some level none of us really
believes we're going to die.
I want to say,
I think that argument's a
horrible argument.
How many of you believe that
there are meetings that take
place without you?
Suppose you're a member of some
club and there's a meeting this
afternoon and you won't be
there, because you've got to be
someplace else.
So you ask yourself,
"Do I believe that meeting's
going to take place without me?"
At first glance,
it looks like you do,
but here's the Freudian
argument that shows you don't
really.
Try to imagine,
try to picture that meeting
without you.
Well, when you do picture it,
there's that room in your
mind's eye.
You've got a little picture of
people sitting around the table
perhaps, discussing the business
of your club.
Uh-oh, I've smuggled myself in
as a spectator.
If, like you--,
I think most of us picture
these things up from a
perspective in a corner of the
room,
up on the wall,
looking down,
kind of a fly's perspective.
All right, I've smuggled myself
in as a spectator.
I'm actually in the room after
all.
So I haven't really pictured
the meeting taking place without
me.
So I guess I don't really
believe the meeting's going to
take place without me.
If Freud's argument for death,
that is to say,
none of us believe we're going
to die,
was any good,
the argument that none of us
believe meetings ever take place
without us would have to work as
well.
But that's silly.
It's clear that we all do
believe in the possibility,
indeed, more than a mere
possibility, the actuality of
meetings that occur without us.
Even though when I imagine that
meeting, I'm in some sense,
smuggling myself in as an
observer.
From which I think it follows
that the mere fact that I've
smuggled myself in as an
observer doesn't mean that I
don't really believe in the
possibility that I'm observing
in my mind's eye.
I can believe in the existence
of a meeting that takes place,
even though I smuggle myself in
as an observer when I picture
that meeting.
I can believe in the
possibility of a world without
me, even though I smuggle myself
in as an observer when I picture
that world without me.
Freud's mistake,
and it's--although I'm picking
on Freud, it's not only Freud
that runs this sort of argument.
One comes across it
periodically.
Within the last year,
a member of our law school here
put forward this very argument
and said he thought it was a
good one.
So people think the argument's
a good one.
It strikes me as it's got to be
a bad one.
The confusion,
the mistake I think people are
making when they make this
argument, the mistake I think
they're making is this.
It's one thing to ask yourself,
what's the content of the
picture?
It's another thing to ask,
when you look at the picture,
are you existing?
Are you looking at the picture
from a certain point of view?
Suppose I hold up a photograph
of a beach with nobody on it.
All right, am I in that beach,
as pictured in that photograph?
Of course not.
But as I look at it,
whether in reality or in my
mind's eye, I'm looking at it
from a perspective.
As I think about it,
I'm viewing the beach from a
point of view which may well be
on the beach,
if somebody draws a painting of
a beach.
But for all that,
that doesn't mean that within
the picture of the beach,
I'm in the beach.
Looking at a picture doesn't
mean you're in the
picture.
Viewing the meeting from a
point of view,
doesn't mean you're in the
meeting.
Viewing the world without you
from a point of view,
doesn't mean you're in the
world.
So although of course it's
true, when I imagine these
various possibilities without
me, I'm thinking about them.
I'm observing them.
And I'm observing them from a
particular perspective,
from a particular standpoint.
For all that,
I'm not in the picture
that I'm thinking about.
So I think the Freudian
argument just fails.
Now, maybe there's some other
reason to believe the claim that
nobody believes they will cease
to exist.
But if there is another
argument for that claim,
I'm eager to hear it,
because this argument,
at any rate,
seems to me to be unsuccessful.
Now, at the start,
I distinguished two claims
people might have in mind when
they say, "Nobody believes
they're going to die."
The first possibility was the
claim was, nobody believes that
they'll ever cease to exist as a
person.
And I've just explained why at
least the most familiar argument
for that claim,
I think, doesn't work.
The second possible
interpretation was this.
Nobody believes their body is
going to die.
That is, the more familiar
humdrum event of death where
your body ceases functioning and
you end up having a corpse that
gets buried and so forth.
Sometimes it's suggested that
nobody believes that either.
Of course, often,
I think, people run together
these two questions.
When they say you don't believe
you're going to die,
do you mean,
you don't believe your body's
going to die?
or you don't believe you're
going to cease to exist as a
person?
Maybe when people make the
claim, it's not clear which of
these things they've got in
mind.
But let's, at least,
try to now focus on the second
question.
Could it be true,
is there any good reason to
believe it is true,
that nobody believes they're
going to undergo bodily death?
Now, after all,
even if you believe that,
well, your soul will go to
heaven so you won't cease to
exist as a person,
you might still believe that
your body will die.
Most of us presumably do
believe our bodies will die.
At least, that's how it seems
to me.
So it's a bit odd to suggest,
as it nonetheless does get
suggested, that no,
no, at some level,
people don't really believe
they're going to die.
Let me point out just how odd a
claim that is.
Because people do all sorts of
behaviors which become very,
very hard to interpret if they
don't really believe their
bodies are going to die.
People, for example,
take out life insurance so
that--well, here's what seems to
be the explanation.
They believe that there's a
decent chance that they will die
within a certain period of time.
And so, if that happens,
they want their children and
family members to be cared for.
If you didn't really believe
you were going to die,
that is undergo bodily death,
why would you take out life
insurance?
People write wills.
"Here's what you should do with
my estate after I die."
If you didn't really believe
that your body was going to die,
why would you ever bother
writing a will?
Since many people write wills,
many people take out life
insurance, it seems as though
the natural thing to suggest is
that many,
or at least perhaps most,
at least many people believe
they're going to die.
Why would we think otherwise?
Well, the reason for thinking
otherwise, the reason for not
being utterly dismissive of this
suggestion,
is that when people get ill,
terminally ill,
it often seems to take them by
surprise.
So I've been having you read
Tolstoy's novella,
The Death of Ivan
Ilyich.
Ivan Ilyich falls,
he hurts himself.
The injury doesn't get better.
He gets worse and worse and
eventually it kills him.
The astonishing thing is that
Ivan Ilyich is shocked to
discover that he's mortal.
And of course,
what Tolstoy is trying to
convince us of,
what he's trying to argue,
by illustrating the claim,
I take it, that Tolstoy is
making, is that most of us are
actually in Ivan Ilyich's boat.
We give lip service to the
claim that we're going to die,
but at some level,
we don't really believe it.
And notice again,
just to emphasize the point,
the relevant lack of belief
here has to do with the death of
the body.
That's the thing that Ivan
Ilyich is skeptical about.
Is his body going to die?
Is he mortal in that sense?
This is what takes him aback,
to discover that he's mortal.
For all we know,
Ivan Ilyich still believes in
souls, believes he's going to go
to heaven and so forth.
So it's not his death as a
person that he's puzzled by.
He may not think he's going to
die as a person.
It's his bodily death that
surprises him,
his bodily mortality that
surprises him.
Tolstoy draws a highly
realistic and believable
portrait of somebody who is
surprised to discover that he's
mortal.
As he puts it,
there's a famous syllogism that
people learn in their logic
classes from Aristotle.
All men are mortal.
Socrates is a man,
so Socrates is mortal.
Ivan Ilyich says,
"Yes, yes, I knew that.
But what did that have to do
with me?"
Well, it may be a kind of
irrationality.
It may be a kind of failure to
conduct the logic.
But we're not asking,
is it rational or irrational to
not believe that your body's
going to die,
we're simply asking,
noting the fact that,
there to seem to be cases where
people are surprised to discover
that they're mortal.
Now, for all that,
notice, I presume that Ivan
Ilyich had a will.
And for all I know,
Ivan Ilyich had life insurance.
So we're in the peculiar
situation where on the one hand,
some of Ivan Ilyich's behaviors
indicate that he believed he was
mortal,
that his body was going to die.
And yet, the shock and surprise
that faces, that overcomes him
when he actually has to face his
mortality,
strongly suggests that he's
reporting correctly.
He didn't believe he was going
to die.
How could that be?
There's a kind of puzzle there
as to--even if,
before we move to the question,
how widespread are cases like
this?
there's a puzzle as to how are
we even to understand this case?
We need to distinguish perhaps
between what he consciously
believes and what he
unconsciously believes.
Maybe at the conscious level he
believed he was mortal,
but at the unconscious level he
believed he was immortal.
Or maybe we need to distinguish
between those things he gives a
kind of lip service to,
versus those things he truly
and fundamentally believes.
Maybe he gives lip service to
the claim that he was mortal.
If you would have asked him
"Are you mortal?"
he would have said "Oh,
of course I am."
And he buys life insurance
accordingly.
But does he thoroughly and
truly and fundamentally believe
he's mortal?
Perhaps not.
We need some such distinction
if we're going to make sense of
Ivan Ilyich.
Well, let's suppose we've done
it.
Still have to ask,
not, are there are ever cases
of people who don't believe
they're going to die?
but rather, is there any good
reason to think that we're all
or most of us are in that
situation,
are in that state of belief
where, although we give lip
service to the claim that we're
going to die,
is there any good reason to
believe that fundamentally we
don't actually believe it?
That's the question we have to
turn to next time.